visit family my parents
first for my health and for the health of
my family so this is very
important this is because we believe that
this virus is very complicated for
everyone so it is important to take
care of ourselves and those around us
[Music]
very good  the war two months ago in
February the two doses and I have not had
any kind of complications small
pain which is normal it seems to me but
still
[Music]
why not
or why is it so important that
he is 17 years old and is also  important
that he may have that he knows about this process
that he knows that it is so important for his
health and also that he wanted to also
when it is the cradle of this I told myself
when I when he just turned 17 a month ago
12 weeks ago and
just  the vaccine came out for the age
come on I go to the family but this is
so important it is very successful very
important to take care of one
's health is very important right
now you don't have to take care of yourself  You have
to take all the measures
and the vaccine is important because it
helps us take care of ourselves, not so much for us
as they agree with
the process today with your son, as you
cannot explain how it went
very quickly, very
very good, also because they came to us
very well  they explained to us they gave us and gave
him all the guidelines that what could
happen to them ask if he had any
diseases before giving the vaccine
very careful but very good for
means your son is a world is my life
and if the positive things for him you
came  with a companion after I was
confirmed I brought my children to
get their vaccine for their well-
being that the day they no longer get sick
with this virus and everything and that they
feel comfortable with the vaccine and you
as a mother because I  It made it so
important to come as a family in a group
because they didn't want to come and they even
forced the suits to vaccinate because
they said they didn't want
to.  You are
going to need your vaccine or you won't get
sick anymore because if
the young man caught us
and already gave him a sideburn, he won't get sick or
anything about
the vaccine then since they were little they
have all their vaccines for you that it
is so important to follow this
vaccination regiment  Well, by elba esther of
them that when they grow up they teach
their children also how to get their
vaccines
from little ones to adults they were
with the family today that tampa if
a family measurement process was done tell me
how your file went
no work was done for us  we came we were
fine because one just didn't want to come
but the others and the other did want to come
well
our vaccines and they don't make us sick
anymore and now that the process was fine they
treated us well the line quickly didn't
take long nothing hurts
I feel fine in  how
much you love them very much because there are only
two of them, there are five that I have but the
other two more during they are
already vaccinated and they were just missing per  or the
youngest and one qualifies as but
I love all of them the same, a message for
the families that
perhaps have not yet received the vaccine but that they come to be
vaccinated for the well-being of themselves and
their children
and right now that they are being given the
vaccines so that they come and get vaccinated,
thank you very much, ladies of the